it was it was a good time Taylor  Lautner's spills on his past romance  with Taylor Swift's your very first  Instagram video you called out Taylor  Swift okay so it's simple you just you  take your arm and you just adapt dad  that's all you got to do it's not my  thing  I'll give you Taylor Swift cellphone  number so it's your right arm yes did  she respond no I did not I did not hear  from her I'm sorry what was that like it  was it was a good time it was a fun fun  few months there but yeah I did I had  fun without the screen green star and  the singer dated for a bit in 2009 right  before she was linked to John Mayer and  who could forget their smooch in the  movie Valentine's Day for the record we  thought Taylor squared was very cute